francia es desde este viernes uno de los
siete países del mundo en donde la
pandemia se ha cobrado más de 60 mil
vidas con un registro total de 610
fallecidos en las últimas 24 horas la
nación vive por estos días bajo un toque
de queda y con su presidente contagiado
demandé macrón cumple su segundo día de
aislamiento se encuentra en un hogar de
retiro cerca del palacio de versalles
dice estar bien y sus palabras son para
no bajar la guardia el handy es ruth
tenemos que cuidarnos los unos a los
otros durante esta época de festividades
eso es hago un llamado a cada uno de
ustedes cuento con ustedes hagamos lo
mejor que podamos nadie está a salvo de
este virus nadie así que resistiremos
todos unidos la vacuna llegará
seguiremos organizándonos para ella y
nos organice en españa la comunidad de
madrid' la segunda región más golpeada
por el virus se dio y rebajó de 10 a 6
el número de personas que pueden estar
reunidas en las fechas de navidad y
además a nivel nacional ya hay fecha
para la vacunación recibiremos las dosis
de la vacuna de variante kaiser
sábado 26 y el primer día hábil acordado
con los socios europeos el domingo
inyecte de diciembre españa empezará a
estas básculas mientras tanto suecia un
país que desde el comienzo de la
pandemia optó por una estrategia basada
en la voluntad de las personas ordenó
desde el 24 de diciembre y por un mes el
cierre de las actividades públicas no
esenciales declarando obligatorio el
porte de mascarillas en horas pico del
transporte público alemania un
territorio considerado al comienzo de la
pandemia como un ejemplo a seguir vive
un pico que este viernes de acá 813
muertos registrados desde el gobierno
reconocen que los meses de enero y
febrero serán los peores
[Música]